hello everyone so my name is Rafael
Townsend I'm one of the head TA for this
class this week Andrews travelling in my
advisor is still dealing with medical
issues so I'm gonna be giving today's
lecture you heard from my wonderful Co
head ta an on a couple weeks ago and so
today we're gonna be going over decision
trees in various ensemble methods so
these might seem a bit like despair
topics at first but really decision
trees are sort of a classical example
model class to use with various ensemble
methods we're gonna get into a little
bit why in a bit but just to give you
guys an overview what the outlines can
be refreshing to over decision trees
then we're gonna go over general on
something methods and then go
specifically into bagging random forests
and boosting okay so let's get started
so first let's cover some decision trees
okay so last week
Andrew was covering SVM which are sort
of one of the classical linear models
and sort of brought to a close a lot of
discussion of those linear models and so
today we're gonna be getting to decision
trees which is really one of our first
examples of a non-linear model and so to
motivate these guys let me give you guys
an example okay so I'm Canadian I really
like the ski so I'm gonna motivate it
using that so pretend you have a
classifier that given a time and a
location tells you whether or not you
can ski if it's a binary classifier
saying yes or no and so you have you can
imagine a graph like this and on the
x-axis we're gonna have time in months
so counting from the start so starting
at 1 for January to 12 for December and
then on the y-axis we're gonna use
latitude in degrees okay and so for
those of you who might have forgotten
what latitude is it's basically at
positive 90 degrees you're at the North
Pole at negative 90 degrees you're at
the South Pole so positive 90 negative
zero being the equator it's sort of your
location along the north-south axis okay
so given this if you might recall the
winter in the northern hemisphere
generally happens in the early months of
the year so you might see that you can
ski in these early months over here and
have some positive data points and then
in the later months right and then in
the middle you can't really ski verses
in the southern hemisphere it's
basically flipped where you can not ski
in the early months you can ski during
the name july/august
time period and then you can't ski in
the later months and then the equator in
general is just not great for skiing
there's a reason I don't live there and
so you just have a bunch of negatives
here okay and so when you look at a data
set like this you've sort of got these
separate regions that you're looking at
right and you sort of want to isolate
out those regions of positive examples
if you had a linear classifier you'd
sort of be hard-pressed to come up with
any sort of decision boundary that would
separate this reasonably now you could
think okay maybe you have an SVM or
something you come up with a kernel that
could protect perhaps project this into
a higher feature space that would make
it linearly separable but it turns out
that with decision trees you have a very
natural way to do this so to sort of
make clear exactly what we want to do
with decision trees is we want to sort
of partition the space into individual
regions so we sort of want to isolate
out things like positive examples for
example and in general this problem is
fairly intractable just coming up with
the optimal regions but how we do it
with decision trees is we do it in this
basically greedy top-down recursive
manner this would be recursive
partitioning okay
and so it's basically it's top down
because we're starting with the overall
region and we want to slowly partition
it up okay and then it's greedy because
at each step we want to pick the best
partition possible
okay so let's actually try and work out
intuitively what a decision tree would
do okay so what we do is we start with
the overall space and the tree is
basically going to play 20 questions
with this space okay so like for example
one question it might ask is if we have
the data coming in like this is is the
latitude greater than thirty degrees
okay and that would involve sort of
cutting the space like this for example
okay and then we'd have a yes or a no
and so starting from like the most
general space now we have partitioned
the overall space into two separate
spaces using this this question okay and
this is where the recursive part comes
in now because now that you've sort of
split this space into two you can then
sort of treat each individual space as a
new problem to ask a new question about
and so for example now that you've asked
this latitude greater than 30 question
you could then ask something like month
less than like March or something like
that and that would give you a yes or no
and what that works out to effectively
is that now you've taken this upper
space here and divided it up into these
two separate regions like this and so
you could imagine how through asking
these recursive questions over and over
again you could start splitting up the
entire space into your individual
regions like this okay and so to make
this a little bit more formal what we're
looking for is we're looking for sort of
this split function okay so you can sort
of define a region so you have a region
and let's call that region R P in this
case for our parent okay and we're
looking for looking for
a split s P such that you have an SP you
can sort of write out this SP function
as a function of J comma T okay where
you so you were J is which feature
number and T is the threshold you're
using and so you can sort of write this
out formally as sort of you're
outputting a tuple where on the one hand
you have a set X where you have the XJ
the the J feature of X is less than the
threshold and you have X's element of RP
since we're only partitioning that
parent region and then the second set is
literally the same thing except it's
just those that are greater than T
and so we can refer to each one of these
as r1 and r2 any questions so far now
okay so we sort of define now how we
would sort of do this we're trying to
like greedily pick these picks that are
partitioning our input space and the
splits are sort of defined by which
feature you're looking at and the
threshold that you're applying to that
feature a sort of a natural question to
ask now is is how do you choose these
splits
all right and so I sort of give this
intuitive explanation that really what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
isolate out the space of positives and
negatives in this case and so what it's
useful to define is a loss on a region
okay so define your loss l on r and so
for now let's define our loss as
something fairly obvious is your miss
classification loss it's how many
examples in your region you get wrong
and so assuming that you have given C
classes total you can define P hat C to
be the proportion of examples in our
okay and so now that we've got this
definition where we had this P hat C of
telling us the proportion of examples
that we've got in that case you can sort
of define the loss of any region as loss
let's call it in this classification
it's just one - max over C of P hat C
okay and so the reasoning behind this is
basically you can say that for any
region you've subdivided generally what
you'll want to do is predict the most
common class there which is just the
maximum P hat C right and so then all
the remaining probability just gets
thrown onto miss classification errors
okay and so then once we do this we want
to basically pick now that we have a
loss defined we want to pick a split
that decreases the loss as much as
possible so you recall I've defined this
region our parent and then these two
children regions r1 and r2 and you
basically want to reduce that loss as
much as possible so you want to
basically minimize loss our parent -
loss of r1 r2 and so this is sort of
here parent loss this is your children
loss okay and since you're picking and
basically what you're minimizing over in
some case is this J comma T that we
defined over here since the split is
really what is going to define our two
children regions all right and what
you'll notice is that the loss of the
parent doesn't really matter in this
case because that's already defined so
really all you're trying to do is
minimize this negative sum of losses of
your children
okay so let's move to this next board so
I started to find this miss
classification law so let's get a little
bit into actually why miss
classification loss isn't actually the
right loss to use for this problem so
okay and so for a simple example let's
pretend so I've sort of drawn out a tree
like this let's pretend that instead we
have another set up here where we're
coming into a decision node now at this
point we have 900 positives and 100
negatives okay so this is sort of a Miss
classification loss of 100 in this case
because you'd predict the most common
class and end up with 100 misclassified
examples and so this would be your
region RP right now all right and so
then you can split it into these two
other regions right say r1 and r2 and
say that what you've achieved now is you
have this 700 positive 100 negatives on
this side versus 200 positives and zero
negatives on this side okay now this
seems like a pretty good split since
you're getting out some more examples
but what you can see is that if you just
drew the same thing again right RP with
900 100 split split
and say in this case instead you got 400
positives over here 100 negatives and
500 positives so most people would argue
that this right decision boundary is
better than the left one because you're
basically isolating out even more
positives in this case however if you're
just looking at your Mis classification
loss it turns out that on this left one
here let's call this r1 r2 versus this
right one let's call this r1 prime r2
prime okay so your loss of r1 plus r2 on
this left case is just one hundred plus
zero okay so just one hundred and then
on the right side here it's actually
still just the same alright and in fact
if you look at the original loss of your
parent it's also just a hundred right so
you haven't really according to this
lost metric changed anything at all and
so that sort of brings up one problem
with the Mis classification loss is that
it's not really sensitive enough okay
so like instead what we can do is we can
define this cross-entropy loss okay
which will define as L cross
let me just write this out here
and so really what you're doing is
you're just summing over the classes and
it's the probability the proportion of
elements in that class times the log of
the proportion in that class and how you
can think of this is it's sort of a this
concept that we borrow from information
theory which is sort of like the number
of bits you need to communicate to tell
someone who already knows what the
probabilities are what class you're
looking at and so that sounds like a
mouthful but really you can sort of
think of it intuitively as if someone
already knows the probabilities like say
it's a hundred percent chance that it is
of one class then you don't need to
communicate anything to tell them
exactly which classes because it's
obvious that it's that one class versus
if you have like a fairly even split
then you need to communicate a lot more
information to tell someone exactly what
class you are in any questions so far
yep the R 1 R 2 for the parent class for
this case here yeah yeah so um for that
case there so you see that I'll try and
reach up there but so it's like say like
RP was your start region right you could
say it's the overall region right and
then R 1 would be all the points above
this latitude 30 line and our two would
be all the points below the latitude 30
line yep
yeah so the question is when you're
trying to minimize this loss here is it
the same as maximizing the the children
loss and sir
now let's see of maximizing the children
loss and yeah it turns out it doesn't
really matter which which way you put it
it's just basically you're trying to
either minimize the loss of the children
or maximize the gain in information
basically yeah let's see yeah you're
right that should actually be a max let
me fix that really quick because you
start with your parent loss and then
you're subtracting out your children's
loss and so the amount left let's see
the higher this loss is yeah so you
really want to maximize this guy make
sense everyone thanks for that
okay so I've sort of given this late
hand-wavy oh sure what's up so that
would be log base two the question is
for the cross-entropy loss is it log
base 2 or log base C it's log base 2
okay yep or sorry I didn't quite hear
that okay so the question is can what is
the proportion that are correct versus
incorrect for these two examples we've
worked through here and so yeah
basically what we're starting with is
we're starting with we have nine hundred
one hundred nine hundred faucets and one
hundred negatives all right so you can
imagine if you just stopped at this
point right you would just classify
everything that's positive right and so
you get one hundred negatives incorrect
that makes it because this is nine
hundred positives and one hundred
negatives so if you just stopped here
and just tried to classify given this
whole region or P you would end up
getting 10% of your examples wrong right
in this case we're sort of talking we're
not talking about percentages we're
talking about absolute number of
examples that we've gotten wrong
you can also definitely talk in terms of
percentages instead and then down here
once you've split it right now you've
got these two sub regions and on this on
this left one here you still have more
positives than negatives right so you're
still going to classify positive in this
leaf all right and you're still gonna
classify positive in this leaf too
because they're both majority class or
the positives are still the majority
class there and in this case and you
have zero negatives you're not gonna
make any errors in your classification
verses in this case you're still gonna
make 100 errors and so what I'm saying
is that at this level so if we just look
above this line at our
right you're making 100 mistakes and
then below this line you're still making
100 mistakes so what I'm saying is that
the loss in this case is not very
informative so this so this P hat okay
I'm being a little bit loose with the
terminal with the notation here but the
P hat in this case is a proportion okay
but you can also easily basically it's
like whether you're normalizing the
whole thing or not
okay so I've started given this a bit
hand wavy explanation as to why miss
classification loss versus cross-entropy
loss might be better or worse we can
actually get a fairly good intuition for
why this is the case by looking at it
from a sort of geometric perspective so
pretend now that you have this this plot
okay and what you're plotting here is
pretend you have a binary classification
problem okay so you have just is it
positive class or negative class okay
and so you can sort of represent say P
hat as like the proportion of positives
in your set okay and what you've got
plotted up here is your loss okay
for cross-entropy loss well your curve
is gonna end up looking like is it's
gonna end up looking like this strictly
concave curve like this okay and what
you can do is you can sort of look at
where your children versus your parent
would fall on this curve so say that you
have two children okay you have one up
here so the places call this lr1 and you
have one down here lr2 okay
and say that you have an equal number of
examples in both r1 and r2 so they're
equally weighted if you take when you're
looking at the overall loss between the
two right that's really just the average
of the two so you can draw a line
between these two and the midpoint turns
out to be the average of your two losses
so this is l r1 + l r2 divided by 2
that's what this guy's okay and what you
can notice is that in fact the loss of
the parent node is actually just this
point projected upwards here so this
would be your L R parent and this
difference right here this difference is
sort of your change in loss does this
make sense any questions okay so we have
this just to recap okay so we have say
we have two children regions right and
they have different probabilities of
positive examples occurring all right
they sort of would fall one would fall
on this point on the curve and say the
other one falls on this point on the
curve then the average of the two loss
is sort of falls on that midpoint
between these two original losses and if
you look at the parent it's really just
halfway between on the x-axis and you
can project upwards for that as well and
you end up with the loss of our parent
what's up
okay so what we're looking at here is
we're looking at the cross entropy law
so you've got this function here this L
cross entropy right and that's in terms
of P hat C's right and in this case here
we're just assuming that we have two
classes okay and so what we're doing is
we're just modifying the P hat see we're
we're changing that on the x-axis and
then we're looking at what the response
of the overall loss function is on the
y-axis and so what I just did here is
for any this curve just represents for
any P hat see what the cross entropy
loss would look like okay and so we can
come back to this for example right and
if we look at this parent here right
this guy has a 10% right it's sort of
like P hat P hat for this guy is 0.1
it's 10% basically or or I guess no in
this case would be 0.9 sorry and then
vs. here in these two cases right your P
hat in this case is one since you've got
them all right all right and then in
this case it's 0.8 all right and so you
can sort of see since these are equal
there's the same number of examples in
both of these the P hat of the parent is
just the average of the pH of the
children okay and so that's how we can
sort of take this LR parent this L R
parent is just half way if we projected
this down all right
let me just erase this a little bit here
if we projected this down like this we'd
see that this is that this point here is
the midpoint okay and but then when
you're actually averaging the two losses
after you've done the split then you can
basically just you're just taking the
average loss right you're just summing L
R 1 plus L R 2 and if you're taking the
average then you're dividing by 2 and
what you can do is you can just draw the
line and take the midpoint of this line
instead
yeah yeah exactly
so yeah really any if there it's a good
point the question was if you have an
uneven split what would that look like
on this curve right and so at this point
I've been making the math easy by just
saying there's an even split but really
if there was a slightly uneven split you
the average would just be any point
along this line that you've drawn and as
you can see the whole thing is strictly
concave so any point along that line is
going to lie below the original loss
curve for the parent so you're basically
as long as you're not picking the exact
same points on the probability curve and
not making any gain at all in your split
you're gonna gain some amount of
information through this split okay now
this was the cross entropy loss right if
instead we look at the miss
classification loss over here let's draw
this one instead
well we can see in this case if you draw
it is that it's in fact really this
pyramid kind of shape
we're just linear and then flips over
once you start classifying the other
side and if you did the same argument
here where he had L R 1 and L R 2 and
then you drew a line between them right
that's basically just still the lost
curve and so in this case like your
midpoint would be the same point as your
parent so your loss of our parent in
this case would equal your loss of R 1
plus loss of R 2 divided by 2 all right
and so in this case you can there's even
though according to the cross-entropy
formulation you do have a gain in
information and intuitively we do see a
gain in information over here for the
misclassification law since it's not
very sensitive if you end up with points
on the same side of the curve then you
actually don't see any sort of
information game based on this kind of
representation and so there's actually a
couple I presented the cross entropy
loss here there's also the Gini loss
which is another one which people just
write out as as the sum over your
classes P hat C times 1 minus P hat C ok
and it turns out that this curve also
looks very similar to this original
cross entropy curve and what you'll see
is that actually most curves that are
successful youth for decision splits
look basically like this strictly
concave function ok so that's what it
covers a lot of the criteria we use for
splits let's look at some extensions for
a decision trees
I'm gonna keep this guy
okay so I so far I've been talking about
decision trees for classification you
could also imagine having decision trees
for regression and people generally call
these regression trees okay
I'm so taking the ski example again
let's pretend that instead of now
predicting whether or not you can ski
you're predicting the amount of snowfall
you would expect in that area around
that time and so like let's I'm just
gonna say it's like inches of snowfall I
guess or something per like day or
something and just like maybe you have
some values up here some high value
because you're it's winter over there
it's mostly zeros over here cuz you're
summer and then you have some more high
values over here and then you have zeros
along the equator again zeros southern
hemisphere over our winter like this and
you can sort of see how you do just the
exact same thing you still want to
isolate out regions and sort of increase
like the purity of those regions so you
could still create like your trees like
this split out like this for example and
what you do when you get to one of your
leaves is instead of just predicting a
majority class what you can do is
predict the mean of the values left so
you're predicting predict Y hat wear
well for RM so but then you have a
region RM you're predicting Y hat of M
which is the sum of all the indices in
RM y I minus y hat M and you want the
squared loss and then you skim sort of I
guess in this case you want to normalize
by the overall cardinality of RM or how
many points you have
and so in this case basically all you've
done is you've switched your loss
function or no sorry that's wrong this
is actually I got a little bit ahead of
myself this is actually just the mean
value would just be this in this case
right it's just you're summing all the
values within your region so in this
case seven nine eight ten and then just
taking the average of that but so then
what you do is what I was starting to
write out there was actually really the
the loss that you would use in this case
right which is your squared loss okay so
like we'll just call that l squared
which in this case would be equal to Y
minus y hat M squared over R M and
that's what I started to write over
there but in this case right you have
your mean prediction and then your loss
in this case is how far off your mean
prediction is from the overall
predictions in this case yep
so that's a really good question the
question was how do you actually search
for you splits how do you actually solve
the optimization problem of finding
these splits and it turns out that you
can actually basically brute force it
very efficiently I'm going to get into
sort of the details of how you do that
shortly but it turns out that you can
just go through everything fairly
quickly I'll get into that I think
that's in a couple sections from now any
other questions okay so this is for
regression trees right it turns out that
another useful extension that that you
don't really get for other learning
algorithms is that you can also deal
with categorical variables fairly easily
and basically for this case you could
imagine that instead of having your
latitude in degrees you could just have
three categories right you could have
something like this is the northern
hemisphere this is the equator and this
is the southern hemisphere okay and then
you could ask questions instead of the
sort like that initial question we had
before where was latitude greater than
thirty your question could instead be is
is I guess this would be is location in
[Music]
northern hemisphere right and so you
could have basically any sort of subs
that you could ask a question about any
sort of subset of the categories you're
looking at it's in this case northern
you would still this question would
still split out this top part from these
bottom pieces here one thing to be
careful about though is that if you have
Q categories then you have I mean you
basically are considering every single
possible sub
set of these categories so that's 2 to
the Q possible splits and so in general
you don't want to deal with too many
categories because this will become
quickly intractable to look through that
many possible examples it turns out that
in certain very specific cases you can
still deal with a lot of categories one
such case is for binary classification
where then you can just the math it's a
little bit complicated for this one but
you can basically sort your categories
by how many positive examples are in
each category and then just take that as
like a sorted order them and search
through that linearly and it turns out
that that yields you in optimal
solutions so decision trees we can use
them for regression we can also use them
for categorical variables one thing that
I've not gotten into is that you can
imagine that in the limit if you grew
your tree without ever stopping you
could end up just having a separate
region for every single data point that
you have and so that's really you could
consider that probably overfitting if
you ran it all the way to that
completion right so you can sort of see
that decision trees are fairly high
variance models and so one thing that
we're interested in doing is
regularizing these high variance models
and generally how people have solved
this problem is through a number of
heuristics okay
so one such heuristic is that if you hit
a certain minimum leaf size you stop
splitting that leaf okay so for example
in this case if you've hit like you only
have four examples left in this leaf
then you just stop another one is you
can enforce a maximum depth and sort of
a related one in this case is a max
number of nodes and then a fourth very
tempting one I've got to say to use is
you say a minimum decrease in loss right
all right and I say this one's tempting
because it's generally not actually a
good idea to use this minimum decrease
in wasallam and you can think about that
I thinking that if you have any sort of
higher-order interactions between your
variables you might have to ask one
question that is not very optimal or
doesn't give you that much of an
increase in loss and then your follow-up
question combined with that first
question might give you a much better
increase and you can sort of see that in
this case where initial latitude
question doesn't really give us that
much of a game we sort of split some
positive negatives but the combination
of the latitude question plus the time
question really nails down what we want
and if we were looking at it purely from
the minimum decrease in lost perspective
we might stomp too early and miss that
entirely and so a better way to do this
kind of loss decrease is instead you
grow out your full tree and then you
prune it backwards instead so you you
grow out the whole thing and then you
check which nodes to prune out pruning
and how you generally do this is you you
take it you have a validation set that
you use this with and you evaluate what
your miss classification error is on
your validation set if for each example
that you might remove for each leaf that
you might remember
so you would use miss classification in
this case with the validation set
any questions
yep the minimum decrease in loss so yeah
of course so you'll recall that before I
was talking about sort of this RP this
loss of our parent versus loss of our 1
plus loss of our two right so when we're
or I had written out a maximization
basically oh to be clear the question is
can you explain a little bit more
clearly what this minimum decrease in
loss means and so you have your loss of
r1 and r2 versus your loss of our parent
right so the split before the split
alright you have your loss before split
yeah loss of our parent and then after
split you have loss of r1 plus loss of
r2 and if if this decrease between your
loss of our parent to your loss of your
children is not great enough you might
be tempted to say okay that question
didn't really gain us anything and so
therefore we will not actually use that
question but what I'm saying is that
sometimes you have to ask multiple
questions right yet to ask sort of
suboptimal questions first to get to the
really good questions especially if you
have sort of interaction between your
variables if there's some amount of
correlation between your variables
okay so we talked about regularization I
said that we would get to run time let's
actually just go up here again so let's
cover that really quickly
okay so it'll be useful to just find a
couple numbers at this point so say you
have n examples you have FB trace and
finally you have D say the depth with
your tree is D okay you've grunt you you
have an examples that you trained on you
with each has F features and your
resulting tree is depth D so a test time
your run time is basically just your
depth of D it's just oh D all right
which is your depth and typically though
not all cases D and sort of about is
less than the log of your number of
examples and you can sort of think about
this as if you have a fairly balanced
tree right you'll end up sort of evenly
splitting out all the examples in sort
of recursively like doing these binary
splits and so you'll be splitting it at
the log of that end okay so at test time
you've generally got it pretty quick at
train time
you have each point so if you return
back to this example you'll see that
each point right once you've done a
split only belongs to the left or right
of that split afterwards all right sort
of like like this point right here once
you've split here will only ever be part
of this region will never be considered
on the other side on the right-hand side
of that split alright so if you're if
your tree is of depth D each point each
point is part of oh the nose okay and
then at each node you can actually work
out that the cost of evaluating that
point for a train time is actually just
proportional to the number of features F
and I won't get too much into the
details of why this is but you can
consider that if you're doing binary
features for example where each features
just yes or no of some sort then you
only have to consider if you have F
features total you only have to consider
F possible splits and so that's why the
cost in that case would be F and then if
it was instead a quantitative feature I
mentioned briefly that you could sort
the overall features and then scan
through them linearly and that also ends
up being asymptotically o of F to do
that okay so each point is that most o
of D nodes and then the cost of a point
at each node is o of F and you have n
points total so the total cost is really
just
is just oh of NFD like this and it turns
out that this is actually surprisingly
fast especially if you consider that n
times F is just the size of your
original design matrix right or your
data matrix right your data matrix is of
size and times F right and then your
only your your run time is going through
the data matrix that most depth times
and since depth is log of n that turns
out to be or generally bounded by log of
n you have generally fairly fast
training time as well
any questions about run time okay so
I've been talking a lot about the good
sides of decision trees right they seem
pretty nice so far however there are a
number of downsides too and one big one
is that it doesn't have additive
structure to it and so let me explain a
little bit what that means
okay so let's say now we have an example
and you have just two features again so
X 1 and X 2 and you can say you define a
line and just running through the middle
defined by x1 equals x2 and all the
points above this line are positive and
all the points below it are negative now
if you have a simple linear model like
logistic regression to have no issue
with this kind of setup but for a
decision tree basically you'd have to
ask a lot of questions that even
somewhat approximate this line what you
could try you're going to say okay let's
split this way something like this and
basically something like that right and
even here you so you've asked a lot of
questions and you've only gotten a very
rough approximation of the actual line
that you've drawn in this case and so
decision trees do have a lot of issues
with these kind of structures where this
the features are interacting additively
with one another ok so to recap so far
since we've covered a number of
different things about decision trees
there's a number of pluses and minuses
to decision trees ok so on the plus side
there actually I think this is an
important point is that they're actually
pretty easy to explain right if you're
explaining what a decision tree is to
like a non-technical person it's fairly
obvious you're like okay you have this
tree you're just playing 20 questions
with your data and letting it come up
with one question at a time
they're also interpret able you can just
draw out the tree especially for shorter
trees to see exactly what it's doing it
can deal with categorical variables
and it's generally pretty fast and
however on the negative side one that I
alluded to was that they're fairly high
variance models and so are oftentimes
prone to overfitting in your data
they're bad at additive structure and
then finally they have because in large
part because of these bursts - they're
generally have fairly low predictive
accuracy I know what you guys are
thinking I just spent all this time
talking about decision trees and I tell
you guys they actually sort of suck so
why did I actually cover decision trees
and the answer is that in fact you can
make decision trees a lot better through
ensemble and a lot of the methods for
example the leading methods and kaggle
these days are actually built on
ensembles of decision trees and they
really provide an ideal sort of a model
framework to look at through which we
can examine a lot of these different
ensemble methods any questions about
decision trees before I move on I I
don't think that's strictly okay so the
question is for the cross-entropy loss
does the log need to be based - and the
answer is I'm pretty sure that is not
very relevant in this case I'm not a
hundred percent sure about that but I'm
pretty sure that the base is a lot good
that makes it
it's cross-entropy loss actually
initially came out of like information
there we have like computer bits and
you're transmitting bits and so it's
useful to think in terms of bits of
information that you can transmit which
is why I always came up as log base to
initial formulation
okay so now let's talk about ensemble
okay so what I want is on Tom blowing
help at some level you can sort of think
back to your basic statistics so say you
have you have excise excise which are
random variables
well sometimes right this is just our V
that are independent identically
distributed and so probably a lot of you
are familiar with this already well you
can call this iid okay now say that your
variance of one of these variables is
Sigma squared
then what you can show is that the
variance of the mean of many of these
variables so let's of many of these
random variables or written
alternatively one over n sum over I of X
I is equal to Sigma squared over N and
so each independent variable you factor
in is decreasing the variance of your
model and so the thought is that if you
can factor in a number of independent
sources you can slowly decrease your
variance okay so I saw that though this
is a little bit simplistic of a way of
looking at this because really all these
different things are factoring together
have some amount of correlation with
each other and so this independent
assumption is oftentimes not correct so
if instead you drop the independence
assumption so now your variables are
just ID right okay and say we can
characterize what the correlation
between any two x i's is and we can
write that down as rho so
then you can actually write out the
variance of your mean as Rho Sigma
squared squared plus 1 minus Rho over m
or no n Sigma squared okay and so you
can sort of see that if your correlation
if they're fully correlated then your
this term will drop to zero and that
you'll just have Sigma squared again
because adding a bunch of fully
correlated variables it's just going to
give you the original variables variance
versus if they're completely d
correlated then this term drops to zero
and you just end up with Sigma squared
over n which gives you the initial
independent identically distributed
equation and so in this case really what
you want to do the name of the game is
you want to have as many different
models that your factoring is possible
to increase this n which drives this
term down and then on the other hand you
also want to make sure those models are
as d correlated as possible so that your
Rho goes down in this first term goes
down as well okay
and so this gives rise to a number of
different ways to Ensemble and one way
you could think about doing this is you
just use different algorithms this is
actually what a lot of people in cackled
for example will do is they'll just take
a core random forest and svm average of
them all together and you know that
actually works pretty well but then you
sort of have to spend your time
implementing all these separate
algorithms which it's oftentimes not the
most efficient use of your time another
one that people would like to do is just
use different training sets okay and
again in this case like you probably
spend a lot of effort collecting your
initial training set you don't want your
like machine learning person to just
come and recommend to you that just go
collect a whole second training set or
something like that to improve your
performance like that's generally not
the most helpful recommendation okay
and so then what we're gonna cover now
are these two other methods that we use
to do Ensemble II and one of them is
called bagging which is sort of trying
to approximate having different training
sets I'll get into that quickly and then
you also have boosting
and just so that you had to have a
little bit of context we're gonna be
using decision trees to talk of a lot
about these models and so bagging you
might have heard of random force that's
a variant of bagging for decision trees
and then for boosting you might have
heard of things like add a boost or XG
boost which are variants of boosting for
decision trees okay so that sort of
covers that a high level would want to
do these first two are very nice because
they're sort of would give us a much
more like independently correlated or
less correlated variables but generally
we're we end up doing these latter two
because we don't want to collect new
training sets or train entirely new
algorithms okay so let's cover bagging
first
okay so bagging really stands for this
thing it's called bootstrap aggregation
okay and so first let's just break down
this term so bootstrap what that is is
this typically this method use and
statistics to measure the uncertainty of
your estimate okay and so what what is
useful to define in this case for when
you're talking about bagging is you can
say that you have a true population P
okay and your training set training set
s is sampled from P you just are drawing
a bunch of examples from P and that's
what forms your training set and so
ideally like for example this different
training sets approach what you do with
you just draw s1 s2 s3 s4 and then train
your model and each one
separately unfortunately you generally
don't have the time to do that and so
what that what bootstrapping does is you
assume basically that your population is
your training sample okay so you assume
that your population is your training
sample and so now that you have this s
is approximating your P then you can
draw new samples from your population by
just drawing samples from s instead okay
so you have bootstrap samples is what
they're called z samples from s and so
how that works is you basically just
take your train your your training
sample okay say it's of like cardinality
n or something and you're just sample n
times from s and this is important you
do it with replacement because they're
pretending that this is a population and
so doing it with replacement sort of
makes it of something hold that you're
sampling from it as a population okay so
that's bootstrapping so you generate all
these different bootstrap samples Z on
your from your training set and what you
can do is you can take your model and
train it on all these separate bootstrap
samples and then you can sort of look at
the variability in the predictions that
your model ends up making based on these
different bootstrap samples and that
gives you sort of a measure of
uncertainty I'm not going to go into too
much detail that because that's not
actually what we're gonna use
bootstrapping for what we want to use
bootstrapping force we want to aggregate
basically bootstrap samples and so at a
very high level what that means is we're
gonna take a bunch of bootstrap samples
train separate models on each and then
average their outputs okay
so let's make that a little bit more
formal
so you have bootstrap samples z1 through
ZM say okay capital n let's just say how
many bootstrap samples you're gonna take
okay you train a model GM okay on Xia
okay and then all you're doing is you're
just defining this new sort of meta
model I'm not putting a subscript on
this one to show that it's the meta
Model T of M which is just the sum of
your predictions your individual models
divided by the total number of models
you have and this is just me writing out
what I was sort of talking about right
up there for bagging it's you're taking
these bootstrap samples and then your
training separate models and then you're
just aggregating them all together to
get this bagging approach and so if we
just do a little bit of analysis from
the bias-variance perspective on this we
can sort of see why this kind of thing
might work
and so you recall we have this equation
up here right there various variants of
the mean is Rho Sigma squared plus 1
minus Rho over N Sigma squared so let me
just write that out here and in this
case our n is actually really just the
number of bootstrap samples so we'll
just use Big M in this case and what
you're doing is by taking these
bootstrap samples you're sort of D
correlating your the models your
training your bootstrapping is driving
down well okay and so by driving this
down you're sort of making this term get
smaller and smaller and then your
question might be okay what about this
term here and it turns out that
basically you can take as many bootstrap
samples as you want
and that'll slowly drive down it
increases M and drive down this second
term and it turns out that one nice
thing about bootstrapping is that
increasing the number of bootstrap
models your training doesn't actually
cause you to over fit any more than you
were beforehand because all you're doing
is you're driving down this term here so
more M it's just less variance all
you're doing is driving down the second
term as much as possible when you're
getting more and more bootstrap samples
so generally only improves performance
and so generally what people will do is
they'll sample more and more models
until they see that their error stops
going down because that means I've
basically eliminated this term over here
so this seems kind of nice right you're
decreasing the variance where's the
trade-off coming in oh there's a
question
yeah there's definitely a bound right
because I'm not gonna define one
formally right now oh the question is
can you define a bound on how much you
decrease row by I'm not yeah so there's
definitely a lower bound yeah lower
bound and how far you can decrease row
it basically comes down to your
bootstrap samples are still fairly
highly correlated with one another all
right because they're still just drawing
it from the same sample set s really
your Z's gonna end up containing about
two for each Izzy's gonna contain about
two-thirds of s and so your Z's are
still gonna be fairly highly correlated
with each other and though I don't have
a formal equation to write down as to
exactly how much that decreases row by
how much that balance row by you can
sort of see intuitively that there is a
bound there and then you can't just
magically decrease row all the way down
to zero and achieve zero variance so I
was saying that you decrease variance
this seems very nice one issue that
comes up with with bootstrapping is that
in fact you're actually slightly
increasing the bias of your models when
you're doing this and the reasoning for
that is because of this subsampling that
I was talking about here each one of
your Z's is now about two-thirds of the
original s so your training unless data
and so your models are becoming slightly
less you know complex and so that
increases your bias in this case yes
yeah for sure so the question is can you
explain the difference between a random
variable and an algorithm in this case
right and so you can sort of at a very
high level you can think of an algorithm
as a classifier that as a function
that's taking in some data and making a
prediction right and if you sort of see
those that whole set up as sort of like
probably the algorithm is giving some
sort of output in the problem holistic
perspective you can sort of see the
algorithm as like a random variable in a
case in this case sort of like you're
basically considering sort of the space
of possible predictions that your
algorithm can make and that you can sort
of see as a distribution of possible
predictions and that you can approximate
that as a random variable I mean it is a
random variable at some level because
it's sort of like based on what training
sample you end up with your predictions
of your output model are going to change
and so since you're sampling sort of
these random samples from your
population set you can consider your
algorithm as sort of based on that
random sample and therefore random
variable itself okay so yeah your
bicycle increased because of random
subsampling
but generally the decrease in variance
that you get from doing this it's much
larger than the slight increase in bias
you get from from doing this random life
subsampling so in a lot of cases bagging
is quite nice
okay so I've talked a bit about buying
about bagging let's talk about decision
trees plus bagging now okay so you
recall that decision trees are high
variance low bias and this right here
sort of explains why they're pretty good
fit for bagging okay because bagging
what you're doing is you're decreasing
the variance of your models for a slight
increase in bias and since most of your
error from your decision trees is coming
from the high variance side of things by
sort of driving down that variance you
get a lot more benefit than for a model
that would be on the reverse hybrid bias
and low variance alright so so this
makes this like an ideal fit for bagging
okay so now this is sort of decision
tree split bagging I said that random
force or sort of a version of decision
trees plus backing and so what I've
described here is actually almost random
for us at this point the one key point
we're still missing is that random
forest actually introduce even more
randomization into each individual
decision tree and the idea behind that
is that as I had that question from
before is this row you can only drive it
down so far through just pure
bootstrapping
but if you can further D correlate your
different random variables and you can
drive down that variance even further
okay and so the idea there is that
basically for at each split four random
forest
at each split you consider only a
fraction of your total features so it's
sort of like for that ski example maybe
like for the first plate I only let it
look at latitude and then for the second
split I only let it look at the time of
the year and so this might seem a little
bit unintuitive at first but you can
sort of get the intuition for two ways
one is that you're decreasing row and
then the other one is you can think that
say you have a classification example we
have one very strong predictor that gets
you very good performance on its own and
regardless of what bootstrap sample you
selects your models probably gonna use
that predictor as its first split that's
gonna cause all your models to be very
highly correlated right at that first
split for example and by instead forcing
it to to sample from different features
instead that's going to increase the or
decrease the correlation between your
models and so it's all about D
correlating your models in this case
okay and that sort of brings so close a
lot of our discussion of bagging are
there any questions regarding bagging
okay
now I've covered bagging let's get a
little bit into boosting and I'll make
this quick
but basically whereas bagging we sort of
saw in the intuition that we were
decreasing variants boosting is sort of
actually more of the opposite where
you're decreasing the bias of your
models okay and also it is basically
more additive and how it's doing things
so versus you'll recall that for bagging
you were taking the average of a number
of variables and boosting what happens
you train one model and then you add
that prediction into your ensemble and
then when you turn a new model you just
add that in as a prediction and so
that's a little bit hand wavy right now
so let me actually make that clear
through an example so say you have a
data set again x1 x2 x2 and you have
some data points maybe some it's
actually just called pluses and minuses
say you have some more pluses here and
then maybe a couple minuses and pluses
here okay and what you say your training
size one decision tree so decision
stumps is what we call them it's you
only get to ask one question at a time
and the reason behind this just really
quickly is that because you're
decreasing bias by restricting your
trees to be only depth one you basically
are increasing their amount of bias and
decreasing the amount of variance which
makes them a better fit for boosting
kind of methods and say that you come up
with a decision boundary okay say this
one here okay and what you're gonna do
is on this side you predict positive
right and on this side you predict
negative it's like a reasonable like
lying that you could draw here but it's
not perfect right you've made some
mistakes
in fact what you can do is you can sort
of identify these mistakes so if we draw
this in red hey you've got made these
guys as mistakes and what boosting does
is basically it increases the weights of
the mistakes you've made and then for
the next decision stump that you train
it's now trained on this modified set
which I subscride over here and so now
you these positives I'll just draw them
much bigger you know you've got big
positives here and some small negatives
and some small positives some big
negatives here and so now your model to
try and get these right might pick a
decision boundary like this and this is
also basically recursive in that each
step right you're going to be reading
each of the examples based on how many
of your previous ones have gotten it
wrong or right in the past and so
basically what you're doing is you can
sort of weight each one of these
classifiers you can determine for
classifier GM a weight alpha M which is
proportional to how many examples you
got wrong or right so better classifier
you want to give it more weight and a
bad classifier you want to give it less
right portion all and I think that the
exact equation used in adaboost for
example is just log of 1 minus the error
of your n model divided lis basically
log odds okay and then your total
classifier is just f of a or let's just
call it G of X again G of X it's just
the sum over m
of alpha and G of M and then each G of M
is trained on a weighted on a reweighed
it actually reweighed 'add and so i've
glossed over a lot of the details here
in interest of time but the specifics of
an algorithm like this are will be in
the lecture notes and this algorithm is
actually known as adaboost and basically
through similar techniques you can
derive algorithms such as XG boost or
gradient boosting machines that also
allow you to basically re-weight the
examples you're getting right or wrong
in this sort of dynamic fashion and
slowly adding them in is additive
fashion to your composite model and that
about finishes it for today thanks for
coming great rest of your week